Some mental disorders can be viewed as
extreme expressions of behaviors that are
otherwise normal.
The seems to be true for anxiety
here.
There is an important principle,
the smoke detector principal that gives
us some insight into our vulnerability
seems to be true of depression and
obsessive compulsive disorders.
Yeah,
there are two general
kinds of explanation.
One is that the disorder is simply the
tail of the distribution who said her is
normal,
selected and adaptive.
That generates a
population level trade off.
I'll remind you of of that
image which expresses that idea.
The other is that disorder results
from the dysregulation of an adjustable
system.
Anxiety needs to be adjusted to the
environment when dysregulated by
environmental mismatch in
genetic predisposition than
a maladaptive behavior can
result.
So let's have a look at anxiety.
Fear and panic are clearly adaptive
in appropriate circumstances.
Fear of snakes and spiders seems
to be innate in some people.
Some fear of strangers
is probably appropriate.
Fear of predators is
certainly appropriate.
Separation anxiety can help infants
to maintain parental support.
People who lack the capacity for fear
and anxiety would probably not survive
very long
with exaggerations of fear and
anxiety can become pathological.
Hear the smoke detector principle,
uh, can give some insight.
When a response is cheap and it
protects from serious injury,
it pays to set the threshold
for triggering that response
at a very low level.
Many false alarms result,
but they do not cost very much and
virtually all real threats do then trigger
helpful responses.
The biological systems that react to
the threats are built of many components
resulting in output distributions that
have frequent centers and rare tails.
So we can combine that idea with
the smoke detector principle.
The tails contain the
math pathological extreme,
such as clinical phobias
and anxiety disorders.
This insight helps us to understand
more than it helps us to treat.
I fear,
but I think the idea is useful and it's
one of Randy nussies real contributions
to understanding the evolutionary
origins of mental disorders.
If the response is cheap,
many false alarms may result,
but they don't cost much and virtually
all real threats do trigger healthful
responses when the threshold is set low.
Yeah.
What about depression?
One evolutionary is that depression is
a part of normal functional variation in
mood. That evolved as a mechanism to
allocate effort in proportion to reward.
In other words,
if you are doing something and you're
getting the feedback that it's not
working,
then depression is one way to mediate
withdrawal from that unrewarding
situation.
This idea fits quite well with the
notion of a complex system that produces
tales of output,
the represent pathological extremes,
so the center of the distribution is
actually functional and it's a way of
keeping people from engaging in activities
where they get punished rather than
rewarded, but the tails of the
distribution are not functional.
Yeah,
both positive manic and
negative depressive extremes
of mood are then seen as
population level tradeoffs with the
central region of the distribution of mood
variation where variation is normally
adaptive and in fact homeostatic,
it regulates behavior
towards functional ends.
We can also take a look at obsessive
compulsive disorder from this same general
framework.
OCD is characterized by ritualistic,
repetitive behaviors and fear that a
small oversight might lead to disaster.
It has substantial heritability and an
incidence of about 1% in the population.
It may very well represent the tail
of a distribution of responses.
Who Center is normally adaptive,
and that center would be habits.
Habits are useful because experience shows
they function well and we do not have
to think about them.
We put ourselves on autopilot
and that releases us to think
about other things, so we can see.
OCD is the exaggeration of a habit
that becomes a destructive fixation.
To summarize, many mental disorders
have easily recognizable counterparts,
emotional states and personality features
that are part of normal behavior,
anxiety, depression, mania, and
obsessive compulsive disorder.
Or a few of the pathological states that
it represent extreme versions of normal
behaviors.
Milder versions include histrionic,
narcissistic,
and dependence disorders.